ezequiel cop el experto en medio oriente
ezequiel buen día gracias por estar con
nosotros y un año después de las
protestas que llevaron a la renuncia del
primer ministro adel abdel madhi como es
el panorama en irak
hablar ir a que se encuentra en nueva
incentiva tanto política como de
seguridad hay un problema de la
referencia política en cuanto a que los
manifestantes activistas dicen que el
sistema electoral impuesto por los
estados unidos parte de la ocupación de
la que en 2005 no garantiza que
candidatos independientes pueden
imponerse en el parlamento entonces lo
que se pide es una reforma política a
pesar de la hecha a destiempo desde el
2019 que alcance que sea de alguna
manera más que el que se pueda extender
un poco más y que alcance a cualquier
candidato independiente pueda
presentarse después también hay un
problema de control del estado
hay un montón de milicias que también
han penetrado el estado está en el
parlamento que han crecido en una
especie de vacío de poder incluso de
seguridad cuando y si se avanza en irak
que han ocupado ciertos roles del estado
entonces lo que estamos viendo es casi
una disyuntiva en quien va contra el
estado o milicias que responden a veces
a intereses extranjeros que puede ser
irán o el propio ejército
de irak y su policía por último tenemos
un problema de seguridad que es un
posible avance y crecimiento del estado
islámico y este último punto de asís que
había nombrado antes era del control del
estado digamos que se agrava cuando y se
va creciendo la amenaza y si va
creciendo y las milicias chiitas ocupan
el lugar que el ejército iraquí no puede
no puede ocupar
bueno y en las protestas del año pasado
se registraron las muertes de cientos de
estudiantes cuál es la posición del
gobierno
adelante los manifestantes que va a
adelantar las elecciones la situación es
la fecha para adelantar la sería a mitad
del año que viene lamentarán te dicen
que eso no es lo que están buscando
ellos dicen también principalmente más
que adelantar elecciones que hace una
reforma del estado donde cualquier
candidato independiente imponer si puede
imponerse un aparato que de alguna
manera replicar cierto sistema sicario
que ya conocemos en el líbano y como
vimos también el líbano irak con todos
esta magnificación es lo que están
diciendo que es más obsoleto que no
garantiza la democracia y que cambiar el
primer ministro no es la solución al
problema de que cándida que el sistema
político de cuajo